he's not throwing himself okay so don't
don't go like tweak your body as much as
you want okay you see I'm just I'm
turning and torquing his elbow and he
can't help but to go so you're not
rolling this means his hand has to get
past the bottom eight heads so 12
o'clock six o'clock I have to get to
about five meaning I'm actively still
working so set your body up for that
let's go
okay a lot of times you do your
horizontal reconciliation is more of a
vertical reference you're trying to get
around this energy and then over the top
of the energy so if you just try to do
this for a zombie yeah like that so your
body you're overlapping circles can't
just do that you have to figure out how
to get over it see I'm doing that
all see we're turning around each other
then going over it we're going to turn
around you see senator visit my centers
with that weapon you see but then I
gotta get over it
what you usually see is the guy gets a
cube right like a little massage turret
and Ryder taps the horse and he gets a
QB throws himself there's no way that
would do that so make sure that you're
just working these two circles
horizontal and vertical wool horizontal
vertical okay and you have to get to
five
so I'm going to move right boom so that
his hand is in my Center and then I'm
going to go over the top of that itchy
in his side boom right there and then I
go over the top of it
I don't want to use my hats I don't want
to use my hands because bricks is low
percentage so I'm gonna do the same
technique without my finger boom
this makes it more of a trap that's not
giving it up that's more important that
my body is moving in the right place and
I won't be able to fall
[Music]
so this this is a kind of yogic exercise
so to speak and other more suspension
cultivating some then key one but we're
gonna start working off of it we're
gonna make it a base because we're
actually going to do stuff based upon it
okay so the the first martial skill that
we're doing here
is this connection right so he like he
moves and I follow I can stick to his
arm okay
that's your right boom so watch this
hand this chants going around that's
semi right you can see the angle
cancellation on the other side so don't
do it here move this around bow then I'm
following it and I need to take one more
turn here so from here can't go here
you're gonna lose it you want to get
back on your side on the front so I'm
here and I turn here
and it's just sticking zero pressure
remember that concept that's how you
stick to it and then I'm just applying
the the circles of the other technique
so it has to get to my spine easy and
then I have to get over it boom boom
okay let's just try that lead to throw
okay so let's work with the ski okay so
he's gonna come in and I have the same
yeah I'm usually the initial but I've
used this far but I'm doing it to
deviate so I can do the first town just
do the first hand and that's what I
watch it so leave the throw off let's
just work on the pay the fate of the
stickiness
[Music]
they off you what you're really doing is
you're feeling the energy and you're
trying to get to the other side of it
yes
don't stop the bunch keep the punch go
punch keeps going okay let's just try
that baby they won't know the speed
right I'm going to start asking for less
of myself I just walk back this one
[Music]
that's gonna guarantee more that you
have this this communion here see that
I'm not doing this so I have that
stickiness so the energies coming in
boom that's it use him a little pulse oh
dang try that's right so
oh and once I make contact I'm sticking
to him okay this key energy comes up
right hey so boom I'm sticking to that
I'm not I'm not doing that you know
that's I mean the less I have to do that
the more I can maintain connection and I
key without having to overtly graph the
higher percentage I'm going to have it
at at full speed on bigger people it's
like this is not as counterintuitive as
you think
you're gonna grab you know you have a
better chance if you grab it but these
prices are so fast you're not going to
be able to drive okay and then
you're not going to be able to to
leverage people who are way too long so
all I'm doing here is keeping this
energy going and I'm not asking for much
I'm only asking for Kazushi that's it so
boom this is it boom if they need once
you have to sushi yeah you have your
other things you see and you're not
doing this
you're having it boom boom pop oh so
you're still striking thereby you're
striking a guy who's like that you see
that so boom here up right there
right there
[Music]
that's all I needed you see it's not
even he's not hitting the ground you get
it there's a delay because I just needed
his balance broken don't don't do this
you should have hit him already Oh
balance that's it that's it
see how he floated too much can't you
see this that's it that was all idea you
see that tiny bit of float so boom boom
that's it if you want you kid you could
just pass him right here over here boom
that that one I just passed the arm I
didn't have it connected to adjustments
let me see that so but I it's the
connection is not a matter of how far I
pull this the connection is the matter
of my body connected to his my body
connected to his through his Center so
you just but the technique is more like
here's his hat alright and I'm here oh
my not hitting high but I'm adding
Kazushi to it so full that's it right
there
don't don't blow him you guys are
looking like this right going here
[Music]
just pop him
you